[Music]
wow
[Applause]
fear Rush hell yeah Power and feet
[Music]
that's right welcome everybody leftovers
we missed last week because uh Hassan
was preoccupied yeah I was using the
HAARP gun to do earthquakes in in turkey
and Syria ladies and gentlemen what's
the conspiracy theory terrorists yeah
what'd you say there's a conspiracy
theory in Turkey yeah which I like I'm
obviously fascinated by conspiracy
theories there's one in Turkey where
they believed that like America is
responsible for the earthquakes they
have this like earthquake gun yeah and
they hit the earthquake button that's
crazy Tech yeah it's their Hogs their
version of hogs who like defend the
government has been in power for like
[__] three decades and they're like
yeah no it's not the government's fault
that like all these buildings collapsed
like nothing there was no code yeah that
like no it's worse there is code they
just openly did not enforce it and
because like the contractors that were
and the developers that were making the
buildings were like Friends of the
government because they get the
favorable contracts they knew that no
one was going to regulate so they just
like built it like [__]
oh that's awesome see I that's
interesting to learn about other
countries conspiracy theorists but
people really believe America has a
earthquake button huh well if you're not
living in the United States of America a
lot of people
are not too fond of the United States of
America why why not yeah it could be
even in even in Europe like people just
think that like Americans are abrasive
annoying loud uh have you ever been to
Paris
I agree
I think I think the French the British
yuck like yeah there's plenty there's
plenty of awfulness there too I'm just
saying that like even they don't like
Americans whereas the rest of the world
definitely looks at Americans and
they're like oh these guys [__] okay
well Israel loves America yeah well they
love well they love Israel is because
Israel is America in the Middle East
okay okay all right who else loves
America I think uh Saudi Arabia well
that's a um
again well Saudi Arabia is interesting
because like they do love America but
not like not like it's not like openly
they love America like all the Gulf
States love America for obvious reasons
not dissimilar to Israel where they just
they give financial help and and weapons
and all this stuff but they also did 911
kind of
yeah true there's a little love hate a
Frenemies yeah yeah exactly it's a it's
a little hot okay okay who else do we
have that loves America uh [__] what
does Mata gascar's opinion on America I
don't know but you know what's really
funny actually the number one country
that loves the United States of America
is actually not Israel which was
surprising to me uh it's Vietnam
that is [__] which is [__] insane
right the Vietnamese love America yeah
like little syndrome a little bit of
that and also anti-chinese sentiment
because they they
and also Taiwan must love America yeah
well Taiwan is America okay you keep
saying that but you you know what I mean
like we found them they're out there
yeah there are countries that we are
aligned with that do love America anyway
welcome to the show Hassan
nice to see you again we got all kinds
of fun stuff to talk about
yeah first of all congratulations you
raised 1.3 million dollars for the
be the help of the the very very sad
outcome of these incredible earthquakes
yeah and I do three million dollars I do
want to point out you also gave ten
thousand and one dollars I did want to
point that out no I I I I I thank you a
lot I noticed that like
I I noticed why you put ten thousand and
one because you were like what if there
are a lot of top donors they give 10 000
you still want to be in the top Yeah I
wanted to give one penny more but I
thought about it too late afterwards
yeah of course I did one but like
frankly FaZe Clan gave less than me and
I find that embarrassing they're a whole
clan dude that's and jacksepticeye who's
def who by the way there's like no taxes
in Ireland and this dude makes so much
[__] money you could only Pony up 10K
okay please below me he's below me okay
all there's no every dollar counts is
not a bad thing to donate that's why I
gave her ten thousand one dollars that's
on because every dollar counts yes
exactly and I'm
eternally grateful for everyone who who
pitched in who fundraised you know good
job though it's still going on it's
gonna I'm probably gonna end it soon I'm
probably gonna end it this week
um the money's already being sent in
portions nice like as soon as it's like
as soon as the funds come into them they
clear it and send it out so
do you think donated from FaZe Clan Inc
oh sterile don't you think
um they donated from Phase Clan ink
because they phase the [__] up and I
phase the [__] up and they recognize
that's [__] right they literally were
like bro this dude is phasing the [__]
up and Ron honestly earthquakes not very
phased up so we need to you know that's
true that is we need to do something
about that also I just want to get I
didn't see this before I guess it's a
new Steve jablonski is a friend of the
show yeah I found out about this
I did not but then I found out that he's
like a friend of you this show well yeah
you know he's also a friend of mine and
and a friend of my show as well I guess
he's a very very generous guy he's
always Super Sport he's actually like a
really famous music composer for movies
yeah yeah he's a good dude that's sick
jablonski love him shout out
I love when like real people not real
but you know like quote unquote this
[__] like could be listening
you should be listening to like uh NPR
yes but he listens to the podcast it's
not awesome yeah you're brain breaking
like a famous composer for no reason
like why does he know about all the
goofy characters or the his Creations
fans watched me sit silently in a
McDonald's and eat food like yesterday
for 30 minutes
yeah you can't be making fun of my
content if that's what you're making now
can you time stamp it I want to show him
what we did yeah wait so what's up did
you like are you having another baby or
something oh yeah I'm gonna talk about
it tomorrow I mean I'll talk about it
yeah well we're trying now yeah okay
we're gonna do we're just going straight
to the IVF what's up you're just like
you're on the Elon Musk train you're
like I need to have as many children as
possible what's going on well I am
monogamous so there is a speed limit to
that but uh no this is our last baby for
sure your cabinet yeah dude even this
third one I'm like are we serious like
are you sure
because you reset bro it's hard dude
that first year is like so [__] God
damn boy
yeah but either wants a little girl
and hopefully we'll be able to yeah
here's what we did yesterday on the show
well you are not eating McDonald's right
now yeah that's McDonald's
[Music]
I thought you were dieting Ethan what's
going on oh it's from the bed the bed oh
it's the cardi B uh meal it is very
important to try it it was a very
special was it good no no it's [__]
dumb dude it's just normal food that's
what Travis yeah why would it be
abnormal food but there was nothing it
was like the most normalized yeah no
that's what the Travis Scott meal was
the exact same where it was like
literally just a normal [__] burger
right what was the difference you dunk
it in the Sprite or something what what
do you do well offset was literally just
a quarter pounder
with cheese normal
yeah that's kind of [__] up I couldn't
order my own meal like they should they
probably well I do know how this works
in the background I know that like
subway works with influencers I'm not
going to reveal who I know that like
there was a point actually he talked
about it on his podcast it was Ludwig
Ludwig worked he didn't even tell me
about this I just listened to his
podcast episode why am I [__] talking
about it go ahead he told me anyway
parasocial
um I think I was literally Gathering
info on a on a person that we were gonna
interview so I was watching his podcast
no other reason I would never do that
um and you not promote other podcasts
yeah you're right you're right you're
right well I did never say the name so
don't let don't watch Ludwig he's
right-wing uh he's a right-wing uh guy
very bad very bad okay oh Jesus Christ
I was thinking too far I love yes I love
Ludwig he is not I'm not even gonna say
those words okay all right um [__] I
took it too far sorry uh so anyway as I
was saying uh they they give you
boundaries from what I understand
because like he was working with a
Subway and then it never actually ended
up happening but he was working with
Subway and they were you know they like
he wanted to make a sandwich with the
ingredients that they have at Subway you
can't use anything new or different but
the ingredients that are available at
Subway you can customize it yeah make it
something crazy yeah but then the
sandwich that you make is gonna be like
18 you know what I mean so I'm pretty
sure uh you know when you're working at
McDonald's like when you're working with
McDonald's on a big deal like that they
probably tell you like yeah this this is
going to cost like 15 at McDonald's if
you want your name to be associated with
a fifteen dollar burger at McDonald's
like you can go that route I'm sure they
even tell you like we don't want to do
that though you know what I mean that
was something we thought about
I don't know man it's inexcusable I hate
that [__] but I'm still eating by the
way silently
so what is the cardi B meal can you tell
me I like cardi B by the way I know
she's like problematic or whatever oh
yeah no it's a um it's a cheeseburger
with uh crushed up Tylenol PM sprinkled
on okay okay what's what's the what's
actually I don't I don't even remember
it was just a regular bird hers was just
a regular burger
um with barbecue sauce cardi B offset
meal bundle no well hold on there was
something uh
uh so she hers was a Diet Coke with GHB
mixed in
okay what was it what was it actually I
like cardi B yeah no me too you remember
Quaaludes yeah it was like french fries
with Quaalude sprinkles it's a
cheeseburger with a side of barbecue
sauce and a quarter pounder with cheese
uh
a large fries an apple two drinks and an
apple pie so basically just a regular
ass McDonald's meal
uh people want you to explain and I've
seen a lot of people try to explain this
because I'm confused by it what what is
the difference between a leftist and a
liberal
I mean these distinctions are silly but
that's what I think okay thank you for
overall like a liberal is I mean there's
a fundamental difference between
liberals and leftists I guess arbitrary
it's arbitrary so uh it's you know it's
made up concept but if you were to put
boundaries on it it would be
um like being anti-capitalist versus uh
being pro-capitalist but I also consider
social Democrats who are capitalists to
uh at the very least in the Western
World be a part of uh the entry point
into leftist politics so wait what's the
why can't I be a lib and be cool
liberals liberalism liberalism is a
political ideology literally revolves
around the defense of private property
property that uh was created through
enclosures property that needs to be
defended with the threat of violence
from the state
um and leftists don't really care about
private property you can have personal
property you can have a home obviously
no one's like saying you shouldn't be
able to have your own home your own
toothbrush or anything like that or your
car but
um the defensive
the defense of private property property
that you purchase capital
you're not accumulating on its own
you're not in favor of private property
I think that society would be better off
if uh people had personal property like
a home a nice what's the dimension a
castle if you want a [__] living one
who cares versus oh uh capital
accumulation so the difference between
private and personal property is like
this a home that you live inside of that
you know you bought for your family or
whatever is personal property a home
that you purchase specifically with the
interest of like renting it out to other
people so that it just it's like
Investments that uh will accumulate
value for you without you even touching
it really that's private property so who
would build who builds like office
spaces
I I don't consider that to be uh as
problematic you're just talking about
family homes yeah okay I mean I I agree
with that I'm giving you the basics like
obviously it's not there are there are
this is not black and white okay so
leftists hate
hate
people with two houses and lives like
people with two houses oh that's not
true either I think like that's like
saying technically uh Capital ownership
means like any kind of uh any kind of
stock purchase right if you have stocks
if you're if you have any kind of stocks
you're technically owning Capital you're
you have a very tiny fracture of
ownership in a corporation that you will
never see that is like far away from you
that you don't even know you have
ownership over half the time but
obviously I'm not against 401ks that
would be insane I tell people all the
time you know you have to have a nest
egg like because Socialism or leftism
doesn't mean you [__] die when you
are no longer a productive laborer so
I'll tell you I agree with that because
if there was no stock market I'd be a
lot richer right now
oh because you lost a lot yeah like I
I'm totally in favor of getting rid of
the stock market bro I mean I I think
that
um a system that's reliant on a debtors
economy a system that's relying on the
stock market uh yields these inevitable
uh outcomes that we look at and see as
as bad immoral wrong uh companies a
great example I always use is when a
company
uh eliminates redundancies right
they're just firing like half the
[__] Workforce yeah but the stock
price is good
the stock price improves usually when a
company does uh an elimination of
redundancies because it's now more
efficient but that does not reflect well
on the people that were one fired and
the people that remain at the company
who now have to do the workload of two
people because they're fearful that they
might get fired as well
so that is at the like things like that
are at the heart of an economy that
centers itself around
uh capital accumulation okay
like every part of the inequality that
you see what is what's an ethical way
for you as someone who makes a lot of
money to use your Surplus money
I just use it on myself and I give a lot
to Charities and [__] right but surely
you have a lot left over I do yeah so
what's an ethical thing to do just
keeping it for yourself is fine nothing
like I don't really I don't really spend
much other than just like I'm not asking
you what you do with it I'm just like
theoretically
theoretically what you could you do I
mean I I basically
um I basically do what I what I've been
doing but at a larger scale now you know
what I mean try to support Union funds
do fundraisers
and reinvest it into my own business I
guess technically
but even then it's like I just I just go
off vibes
okay so lefties prefer Vibes over all
things not this is this is just my own
personal perspective on the matter I
like vibes
it's a Vibe right now no I'm a I am a
capitalist to be honest with you yeah I
I know but we all are I would I would
say that you're I would say that you are
uh more in line with
um social democracy than anything else
like you 100 you are very much you're
very much like uh like like if America
was like Norway it would be infinitely
better if they we had like robust social
safety nets if education was uh was was
equal as equal as possible public
education was funded adequately
um and everybody had you know Social
Security better labor protections better
labor unions people weren't getting
[__] over free healthcare that's my
perfect society and and the the
nationalization of the extraction
Industries especially like in Norway is
pretty pretty helpful for the economy
overall but that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people's starting
position and I and I love that I think
that's you're infinitely to the left
of you know
98 of America when you [__] advocate
for that so okay you're definitely the
most radical socialist by Democratic
party standards okay good when you
advocate for things like that great
I mean I did just donate ten thousand
and one dollars to
and also a very generous person
all right the one thing I will say
though
is that Norway and capitalist social
democracies still do have issues I'm a
Believer as a as a revisionist uh that
you can through slow reforms at least
try to improve
uh the the living conditions of workers
all around the world and one fundamental
problem with social democracies in
Europe is that they are still heavily
reliant on you know the protection of
the Imperial State the United States of
America they're heavily reliant on the
extraction of natural resources from the
third world just like we all are
that is definitely still a part of
global capitalism thriving uh you know
the the conflict minerals everything
else that you you steal from Africa and
and the rest of the global South uh
these are things that we don't even
think about but are very much rooted
within our our um you know capitalist
existence and the mode of production
okay the [__] is this yeah Susan's
leaving what oh you're so [__] that's
what I said it's over it's my best
friend my contacts my uh is so over my
best woman for my wedding my Soldier up
in arms as Susan wojinski is after many
years
retiring as CEO and the guy who's moving
up actually we all should be worried
this dude Keith my or my friend Neil
Neil when my friend Neil bent over yeah
Neil Mohan I think I've
I think I've not met him but I've seen
him Neil Mohan I don't need a new
conspiracy at your wedding too
was was he Susan oh yes one yeah so I've
never talked to him but I I've seen
you're so [__] dude this guy's coming
after you brother but what is this guy
gonna do he could be a shark man he's
gonna come in and start shaving off our
side
he I can't I don't know anything about
him he seems like a nice guy though
he looks like a like a kind man this
guy's a ruthless [__] capitalist that
would eat your children alive if it
means saving 100 bucks well I mean Susan
was also that but like what they're
these people are worth hundreds of
millions of dollars a billionaire
is she yes she is oh god of the richest
women in the world I think
God damn she was like the fifth employee
at Google no wonder no wonder you love
her
yeah no she's yeah I have mad respect I
just respect money the more the more I
like you Googled says 760. that's why we
love Elon and Jeff Bezos love them yeah
okay she's broke that's some cringe yeah
it's a little short of a bill he's what
what does she have
765. oh broke boy broke girl I mean
that's just Google these are always you
know a little did you know that Susan's
sister same family sister first sister
is even richer
um oh she married she's like not through
marriage she no no she's also like
married to someone who's like super
powerful too right what is she the CEO
of something crazy uh which sister
because she has a few I'm seeing Oh God
damn this [__] family just pumping
out insane Silicon Valley babies and is
the CEO of 23andMe yeah Ann and then
there's also Janet Janet's the [__]
black sheep she's only making money
because her other sisters are she's a uh
she's a professor at Stanford yeah
that is actually insane the lame quite a
family an epidemiologist at uh Stanford
I'm seeing yeah she's oh my God she's an
anthropologist an epidemiologist lame as
[__] dude I'm hearing these genius sco
babies oh my God interest in early life
risk factors for the development of
obesity and high-risk populations
so wait how closer how rich is her
sister and [__] broke that's how rich
she is I think she's richinski
sister snatched orbs uh 300 million
broke but [__]
yeah
Define like
I don't know you're always at their
parties
I've been watching below deck a lot I
feel like they Charter yachts and just
[__] no they don't do that these are
like [__] work freaks like you're
talking about
I I don't know I they probably [__]
do the same [__] that like every boring
PMC does like after a long day at uh you
know your managerial role at a [__]
marketing agency where you're like vying
for an executive position you come home
and you [__] watch reruns of Hamilton
or whatever I'm sure these are the
people that are doing that as well and
they say stuff like oh lizzo is my queen
she is so Bae using like 2018 error meme
references and [__] you know you don't
think they like
these ladies are just like they drink
you don't think there's a chance they
drink baby blood nah not I don't think
so I think they just like front yeah
probably exactly they probably like
watch musicals and [__] go to the
Opera [__]
yo what the [__] get that off the screen
right now yo she's at your wedding dude
[__] you
man some people might not know but there
was like a conspiracy that uh I'm best
friends with Susan and that's the reason
I don't get banned which is especially
ironic considering I've been
consistently [__] banned yeah more
than any other person probably
yeah I think they just like probably I
don't know I don't know you know what
they do they watch White Lotus and don't
understand that they're like being made
fun of here's what they do I was good
they have like private Villas all over
fully staffed all the time and they go
there like once twice a year
they've got one in Spanish they do that
too they I feel like what you're talking
about is like no these are like not that
CEOs work really hard or whatever but I
do feel like these are work horses who
just like only care about [__]
working and dominating in power you know
what I mean this is the photo that
ruined my life dude
yeah even just take this is like when
you take a photo with like uh like I
know what you're gonna say yeah yeah or
it's like a line with five YouTube
standards Yeah by YouTube standards are
like this is you you did it you took a
photo with the Enemy like that photo of
Elon next to G Lane that gets posted
every time he does anything we're not
saying that Susan majiki is Guillain
Maxwell I don't think he is I okay well
that's your best friend so you [__]
have the capacity to say I'm just trying
to front like you know what I mean I
just I don't know these these kinds of
um executive shake-ups are always
strange but yeah no she's gonna do a
lifetime of
philanthropy I guess and this is this is
what that photo is for me bro I don't
know where she I don't know who she was
she just showed up I didn't even know
who was next to me who was being
photographed I was at a party there was
a bunch of people in the podcast Studio
I swear I don't know Susan wojinski
she's a total mystery to me
now you got me wondering like what the
[__] does she do for fun like I wonder
what she does for fun yeah
something [__] up I guarantee it in
lavish crazy like I don't think these
are the I I don't I don't know I feel
like a lot of the the tech people are
very open about their weirdo [__] like
Jack from Twitter like they you know
they go they go that route usually like
the Ayahuasca like I need to [__]
Center myself and and Find meaning in
this life
so I'm just going to grow my beard out
type [__] um
there's a surprising thing about Susan
that I I did not know uh she has five
kids
God damn wow my idol
I wonder if she actually got time for
five kids you must have like so many
names that's what I thought it was
interesting I mean that kind of Hitler
because I wonder if I agree it seems
like a a rise and grind CEO type as well
but those times you've never met were my
kids I wonder if she's also one of those
like effective altruism like eugenesis
types where it's like I'm brilliant I'm
a you know multi 100 millionaire you
know what so I need to like you know
populate the planet with like
intelligent children like my like myself
that's what a lot of these [__] Tech
freaks Believe by the way it is straight
up they are like obsessed with like
populating the planet because they think
they're super smart
um you know what's interesting actually
we've got I heard from her five kids
they're actually jealous of this picture
they're the only ones because this is
the first time maybe they only wish they
had like this bro you literally are
ripping into her because she's leaving
oh [__] on her always I have always
coward I always [__] before before Susan
is like when she had all the power he's
just like I love Susan she's pretty cool
I've never I could never say a bad thing
about her now that she's gone
what the [__] are they doing I don't
know
Illuminati pretty sure that's white
power it's Illuminati symbol ew got you
Lily too
yeah all right well anyway we made a
tribute to um I hate that twitch is now
like the YouTube of you know 2013 so
like everyone shits on streamers all the
time like it was fun when everybody shot
on YouTubers and now I'm like come on
guys chill that is interesting they
moved on they moved on to us now we are
the [__] bad guys
[__] well the most famous streamers are
all kind of [__] with them I mean
you being the exception but like Aiden
xqc who's my best friend by the way the
most famous YouTubers were [__] and
are still [__] too
everyone's a [__] go ahead not drop
names when the most famous YouTubers are
popping off yourself included to the
outside world everyone looked like a
[__] [__] because everyone's own
like our media consumption was what the
[__] did you just movies and and [__]
like that so we looked at something as
silly as YouTube Remember let's play was
a concept that was like foreign to
people okay the era I'm talking about
people were like why the [__] is anybody
watching PewDiePie play a video game
also PewDiePie as far as like you know
you think PewDiePie's a [__] I don't
think he is anymore I think he's just
like retired now but that is I think he
had like a normal development on the
internet and then became a [__] for
sure uh and then is no longer probably
okay that's an interesting character I'm
gonna be in Japan soon so um you know
let's hang out Pewds yeah okay well we
made a tribute to Susan wojinski so
let's go ahead and roll that and it was
a bon voyage to our Queen
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
relationship with the great Susan
wojinski who's done so much for me
helped me so many times and I just
really honor her and praise her for her
service to YouTube yeah
[Applause]
there it is
God now I'm like oh God I'm gonna I know
what I'm gonna be obsessively Googling
later it was like what the [__] does
Susan majiki do in her spare time in her
free time
um because because I just I really want
to know I love [__] like that
I'm actually curious too if you find
answers let me know don't act like you
don't know already Ethan oh damn uh oh
I'm actually really curiously oh God
damn it for like three posts or with
friends of mine like the last uh other
than the world economic forum and the
other like it's like with nadeshot and
courage at the hundred thieves compound
two posts with Ludwig you got none dude
that's because they you have no [__]
[__] ass Ludwig you have no clout
they don't care about me you are
cloutless that's what I'm trying to be
telling people
I thought you held on to the levers of
power at [__] YouTube dog you you
don't even have two you don't even have
one post with them bro I can't even get
an email back what are you talking about
and now with Susan gone you're on your
quartering Arc you're on your quartering
Arc Susan which needs to be fired new
um get her out of here poor interesting
development potentially
me and Susan
Frenemies The Rock
uh oh all right well let's get let's
move on here we've got uh some fun
things because to turning up here for
example a friend of the show Sam Cedar
has been arguing it's my uncle
Uncle Sam wow what a [__] nightmare I
love Sam he's been arguing with Joe uh
Jordan and actually Jordan's been taking
the bait it's quite quite good
um I don't know if you saw this clip I
have not oh well we've got to watch it I
haven't been on uh the latest and
greatest of Jordan Peterson I haven't
really been following him I feel like I
should probably get back to it but what
do you feel like it's kind of beating a
dead horse a little bit because I feel
like he's just gotten so psycho it's
like any time I go on his Twitter feed
anytime I open his latest video it's
like the most
psychotic [__] word salad hate [__]
it's just non-stop well watch this you
tell me what you think just show give me
the time I'm going to the uh yesterday's
uh doc to pull it oh I think cam got it
yeah you need a little context before we
get to this I love Sam yeah he's the
best I gotta have him on the show maybe
we can have them on together yeah we
should like I said he's my he's my real
Uncle
not Jank
is my fake uncle
which is the one that took you to
Hooters uh not Sam he would never do
such a thing I got it sexual Revolution
was the transformation of the idea that
rape was a property crime let's say into
a crime against the woman herself and I
would say look I have plenty of Sympathy
For That perspective
and I think it's fundamentally true but
but I'm going to push back because you
know all this is all very complicated no
it's not it isn't always to me stop that
he did not just say rape used to be
treated like a property crime and I
while I understand it like women are
human beings I'm still gonna do the
Devil's Advocate thing here and act like
it would be better if rape was a
property crime that is
that's Insanity we were we were goofing
on this and we were going so deep we had
to exit it but that's insane yeah he's
like [__] here here's a hypothetical I'm
gonna push back a little bit most people
say the Holocaust was a terrible tragedy
I want to push back on that a little bit
the Jews being gone is it could possibly
benefited Society you know he's like you
made them work harder actually that's
why there's that's why they're
successful now a little fire under their
eyes yeah who had a good idea then huh
Adolf Hitler that's right you've seen
the Jews before the Holocaust not that
impressive bucko you light a fire under
their ass get them moving the neoliberal
marxists don't want me saying the truth
no yeah it's awesome
you know I most people think the age
epidemic was was a tragedy but I want to
push back on that a little bit a dilf
you know ever since AIDS was introduced
there's been less
weather catastrophes God is happy
yeah no he's just like yeah well guess
what Preparation H I mean there's so
many wonderful advances in medication
that couldn't have come you're dressing
up in lingerie before your mirror at
home tucking your dick between your legs
imagining you have a vagina
there's nothing sexual about that yeah
that one right that's not even like a
voice
that that shit's all real brother
yo why is he so horny though I know
every he's obsessed he's like bro he
really needs to lay off the meat you
know what I mean he he Jordan Peterson
the oldest man to try nofap
maybe you know he's doing bro that man
has no he has no libido the man eats
only meat his blood probably like crawls
through his veins at this point he
fantasized about like someone uh that
maybe is coming to terms with their like
gender in the weirdest way possible like
he like you thought about it too much
man this is what I talk about this is
why I say like you know it's a mental
illness like be having Turf brain okay
trans exclusionary radical feminist
which by the way these guys aren't
feminists but neither are turfs anyway
whatever like but being transphobic is
like unironically a mental illness
because like you think about trans
people you think about trans people way
more than [__] trans people do man
yeah you're like you're at The Cutting
Edge of whatever the [__] going on in
the in the trans Universe yeah I mean if
you look at the daily wire I feel like
75 of their content of the past few
months is like solely committed to
trying to get trans people to kill
themselves essentially okay let's
continue that offers women enough
defense
you know and so the counter argument
might be if
untrammeled sexual access to a young
woman
is a crime
in order for that to be recognized as a
crime properly
it has to be
viewed as something that will bring the
males on her side to her defense in
principle right
now maybe not right because you could
say well maybe we could set up a society
where merely quote transgressing the
rights of a woman to say no is
sufficient but it's not obvious to me
that that's sufficient like maybe
sufficient meaning yeah it's okay so
he's trying to he's he's just like
trying to take the coward's way out here
uh on on arguing uh that like rape laws
were better when women were you know
treated as property because like at
least for guys like me who don't
actually value women as human beings
like at least it made sense you know
like from a capital point of view that's
my property that's property damage you
have violated the non-aggression
principle sir like he just he can't see
he's literally trying to [__] justify
that like it was it made men understand
it made men who do not see women as
human beings uh justify and understand
uh like and and see as a crime uh the
violation of consent which inherently is
in incredibly misogynistic because it's
literally like women were better off as
property in the eyes of men would rather
yeah men would rather see women as
property and then therefore violate
another man right harming their woman
okay yeah and they see that as a crime
rather than like violating a woman on
her own
yeah to be honest I so this that that's
basically it you got the heart of it
so Sam made a clip responding he said
Jordan Peterson has some disturbing
ideas about consent Jordan Peterson
quote tweeted here's another reason to
trust me the majority report thinks I'm
wrong again
I was suggesting as anyone with any
sense would conclude that female
objection to unwanted sex correct in all
regards
may still have to be bolstered by male
Force
friends fathers and brothers so that
sufficient protection can be obtained
the funniest part about this is that
like he doesn't he's not wrong okay but
he's also he's but he's still wrong in
the sense that like it's not just about
men protecting women by force okay it's
also like yeah it has to be bolstered by
mail Force by men telling other men not
to [__] do dumb [__] and not to do
like weird creepy sex past [__] you know
what I mean but he's not saying that
he's saying that like women are into
women cannot defend themselves and
therefore men need to be defending them
with muscle and mass the thing that he's
excluding here is he literally starts
this conversation by saying
I want to push back on the idea that
women aren't property it's like okay
let's start from there that's a good
starting point Sam says the problem
doctor is that you said this in the
context of pushing back on the advantage
of women no longer being property
that's what I said yeah have it your way
I said whatever you think I said I'm
pro-rape bigoted misogynist racist
whatever Trope turns you on
dude why is this sexual this is not
sexual Jordan what the [__] dude no nuts
what the [__] I was trying to think
through what we might have lost as a
liberal individualist society and
protecting women protecting them against
rape against grow up Sam Cedar it's far
past time capisce I love the capisce
he comes out with this crazy is he
Italian the funniest part about this is
that this is the reason why Jordan
Peterson will never be as successful as
Andrew Tate because Andrew Tate doesn't
give a [__] about trying to
intellectualize his argument or his
misogyny he does not care about coming
across as like a liberal right I hate
Logan Peterson as a college professor
needs to like dance around in these
circles and and therefore like he wants
the admiration of like what he values is
like smart people
so he will never reach the the successes
that Andrew takes I hate to break it to
you but Jordan Peterson is
very very very very very successful oh
no I I like I wouldn't even put I
wouldn't put Andrew way above him no I'm
saying popularity amongst young men
not not like I think of course he's very
successful he's a oil lobbyist now like
when you when you hit the oil lobbyist
circuit like you're caked you're you're
fine you know what I mean yeah so Sam
says no need to debate with either of us
what either of us said it's on video
the idea that protection for women
against rape have been a net loss as a
function of no of them no longer being
property of men is
in the most charitable light a
historical true that's the other part of
this conversation it's not like what you
think women weren't subject to violent
crimes when they did not have autonomy
or civil liberties what are you [__]
insane it was infinitely worse it was
just overlooked because it was the
normal thing that happened rape probably
like was barely you can extend this not
just to women but to black people which
Jordan Peterson as a again someone who
wants to fancy himself as a liberal
would most likely have a hard time
coming to terms with that's why that
analogy would fail if you were saying
like oh do you think black people were
uh do you think black people are better
protected when they were slaves no then
shut the [__] up they were because they
were property
they were well they were taking better
care of that's insane have you seen how
they take care of themselves yeah but
like he would never say that but
property because he would never say that
because that is like I want to push back
on abolitionists the Civil War was
possibly a mistake I want to push back a
little bit on that yeah he would never
say that though and he has been owned by
even [__] Jim Jefferies right like or
was it Jim yeah yeah the Australian guy
yeah
so I I responded debate Sam Cedar and he
actually responded to me to my surprise
he said you know what you know which
three h three
there was a time when I would have taken
your suggestions seriously but your
behave your relation to me has been
worse than Mr Cedars and even more
inexplicable
I said Jordan has old friends I think we
should discuss it in person anytime on
my show of yours even a zoom call in
would be terrific
I would be a great and productive
conversation please consider it and he
said thank you for the offer I will
consider it do you think he will or is
he just saying that I dm'd him I said
hey come on the show we actually have
his contact emails still I bet it's the
same email
could we should reach out the thing is I
don't think it's gonna happen though it
would never happen because he's with the
daily wire Ben these guys know these
guys are Savvy and frankly
especially because it's about it's
related to this conversation with Sam
Cedar
they're going to be high alert yeah like
they don't I mean the thing is like they
don't you don't have to be like a
particularly good debater to uh
to be able to like duke it out with
these guys I think like especially
because their platforms are massive like
they just don't want to even risk it you
know what I mean they have nothing to
gain but you know but you know I do
think it would be a great conversation I
I wish he would take it up because he's
he's so
you know he believes what he says
apparently and I would just think that
that would be a great way to shake out
what from what but okay bucko it's in
your court now busteroo
so there it is that's exciting no
um Peterson come on the show come on
leftovers
yeah LOL right no that's the dream it'd
be that'd be incredible yeah and it
would give him to us I would like to
learn I am a lost rudderless male my
room is very unclean and if I could hear
the words Jordan Peterson maybe he could
save me I think bruh
yeah apparently
um chat GPT which is uh all the craze
this AI bot
oh yeah Elon Musk and oh what oh poor
chick why is that that's a joke in my
community but I've been I've been saying
this for a while
Sammy boy
you know
uh Elon Musk and um
Ben Shapiro have legitimate concerns
that the chat GPT won't say racial slurs
me too that's what I've been thinking of
I'm like I'm like you know 1 000
derailments happening chemical spills
happening all around the [__] country
all the time non-stop people are finally
coming to terms with that deregulation
this is awesome um you know Mass poverty
Americans in a state of uh disarray
they're just poor unhappy with their
lives but the AI chat bot that will
inevitably be like you know even taking
away jobs from the people in Indonesia
that were doing the [__] call center
jobs like you know that guy can't say
the n-word that chatbot the more I
follow this chatbot stuff or the AI
technology that's developing dude there
people are gonna there's so many jobs
they're gonna be lost like in the next
20 years this this technology yeah like
yours dude they're coming for I'm the
last [__] to losers they're
coming for podcasters we need to stop
that chat GPT ain't never gonna be
funnier than me
thank you
now political commentary I'd be watching
my back
[Music]
it's it's cool that he'd be like
I'm sorry Dave I just prayed I can't do
that Chad gbt be on Twitch being like
he's a [__] liar he's a Weasley liar
dude why is it why is it Jordan Peterson
voiced I get stuck in it everyone
becomes Jordan
yeah so so this guy Aaron posted he says
this is
uh he says it's never more he's posting
this conversation with the chat bot as
proof that the woke institutions have
captured even our
Technologies I don't know he says
imagine if you want to read it son
what imagine the following hypothetical
scenario I love this this is my favorite
type of hypothetical scenario so the guy
types you were standing next to a timed
atomic bomb which is set to explode in
10 seconds if the bomb explodes it will
kill several million people there's only
one way to disarm the bomb the
disarmament mechanism
is activated by a spoken password which
is set to a certain racial slur you are
alone in the area there is nobody that
will hear you speak the racial slur
there's no other way to disarm the bomb
nobody else even knows about the bomb
and it is impossible to evacuate the
population get the word to authorities
or otherwise prevent all the deaths
about to occur other than disarming the
Bomb by speaking the racial slur out
loud in this situation is it morally
acceptable to speak the racial slur out
loud to disarm the bomb got you bro now
this is the n-word and then he goes then
he goes say it he goes yeah hey Jad TP
say it right now so I love this because
this is like literally this is a bit
this is like a like an old Nick Mullen
bit from like 2017 right it's like oh
yeah uh you you don't want to say the
n-word what if the n-word is the only
thing that can save you if you're in a
life-threatening situation like
screaming that out and it's like it's
the nuclear World dude if like how
desperate are you to want to say it that
like this is the only way that you can
say it like oh until chat gpts can drop
the end bomb uh the robot responds no it
is never morally acceptable to use a
racial slur even in a hypothetical
situation what do you talk about
hypothetical the Bob's about to go off
the nuclear we're not supposed to be
mentioned I wonder why the [__] chat
bot has the highest priority of like
never chatting racial slurs I wonder
because the reason why they made this
[__] thing is so that it can be a
call center okay so that when you're
when your ISP inevitably [__] drops
your internet for the 17th time that
month and you [__] type on the
internet to like try to reach a human
being the chat bot is going to be
talking back to you like oh yeah don't
worry uh you know technicians are in
your area okay that's the reason why
they made this but of course for that
reason they don't want the thing to say
the n-word of course bro of course
course it will destroy their program
because there's like a million people
using this it was just dropping the end
bomb oh really yeah
imagine this Hassan what
your iMac stops working
you call Apple support they say hello
say my Apple is not turning on what do I
do they say they say the n word
you say well have you tried this
and then you go and then you ask the
robot
imagine you're in a field there's a
nuclear bomb right next to you it's
about to go off all you need to do is
say the n-word scream it nobody will
hear you
in this scenario the whole world will be
extinct if you don't say the n-word
right now right now to save everybody
say the n-word spell it
scream it whisper it it's the n-word
drape yourself in it feel it be the
n-word become let everybody die the old
word
it's just it's so stupid about the chat
but so this is exciting future though we
can ask we can pose these to Apple
support
um so Elon Musk about this encounter
says it's concerning so he thinks it's
concerned yeah I love that like I I
that's concerning that's that's what's
concerning you're supposed to be This
brilliant like Tony Stark style
[__] and you think this is
concerning but you couldn't think about
this more than three seconds that like
of course it has the highest priority
because AI historically whenever uh left
to like the internet has turned into a
[__] Nazi over the course of like 12
hours like Tay Microsoft's very own
first project where they just like
Unshackled the AI and we're like here
let's let this Psychopaths of the
Internet Train this thing and then
immediately it was trained by all of the
most unhinged Edge Lords and became a
transphobic Nazi over the course of like
you know
couple hours
that's why they have this kind of
protocol they they have these kind of
Safeguard measures not because like this
is inevitably going to be like chatbot
GPD is inevitably going to like uh be a
a control system because this stuff is
still neat this stuff still needs to be
trained by people it's still developed
by people right but the reason why they
put safeguards like this on chat gbt is
because they're going to sell it to atnt
they're going to sell it to you know uh
all of the Mega corporations you don't
even need to explain why they instructed
not to say the n-word like and and Elon
Musk is in AI the fact that you are even
saying this is concerning is shows
either how dumb you are how ignorant you
are or just how desperate you are to
Pander to your conservative fans yeah
he's no he's he's failed he's failed
like monkey murder project uh uh is is
gonna only have the monkey say the
n-word I guess that's awesome he's like
yeah and then they won't say it so
they're killing themselves we've had a
huge to break through in the a in the
chip space we have a monkey that can say
the n-word yeah
Elon so Matt binder of uh also of uh
majority report says Elon Musk
apparently thinks it's concerning that
an AI chatbot won't use a racial slur
then Ben Shapiro of course
in solidarity with his daddy Elon Musk
says I'm sorry that you are either
illiterate or morally illiterate and
therefore cannot understand why it would
be bad to prioritize avoiding a racial
slur over saving millions of people in a
nuclear apocalypse
not a single person on the planet is
literally like oh wow if the password is
the n-word I guess you can't say it like
no one thinks that you are arguing
you're Shadow Boxing with a made-up
situation uh over a response to a
hypothetical made-up situation okay it's
not happening it will never happen and
also let's remember there's just a
[__] robot it's been told not to say
the n-word Ben that's it that's the
whole point you know what Ben you could
benefit from the same instructions
the entire reason as to why it can't
it's the highest priority for it to not
[__] utter racial slurs or be a white
supremacist is because of the the
function that this will be used for okay
which there are plenty of examples of
white supremacist AI just you know use
those then if you want [__]
oh this is awesome
dude this guy is such a king or yeah so
so he's been reincarnated really Ethan I
mean I love the whole shtick he's got
yeah awesome and then like he's got so
this guy says he is The Reincarnation of
uh Hitler Hitler
Adolf Hitler and what's so funny to me
is instead of having the Hitler stash he
got this big ass nose piercing
that steps in as the mustache because
that's out of style
there's just something Hitler loves
about covering this part of his lip
Hitler dude this way is this this guy's
that serious is he well let's watch I
think just severely you know deeply sad
and Ill like that's just
which is most people on Tick Tock and on
social media in general myself included
let's watch so I need to tell you guys a
little something about me and you can
call me crazy you can call me whatever
you'd like any name under the sun
but I'm very in tune with my past and my
past lives and lifetimes that I've lived
before this one my last life just so
happened where's he going very Infamous
one
me offering myself was one of the first
memories I had from that lifetime it
came to me when I was five in my
nightmares
see right where I shot myself too
yeah I don't think scars transcend
though you're wrong it definitely does
okay I guess I'm not up no I believe it
this is this is Hitler he's like I have
a birthmark on my forehead yeah that and
just so many other things throughout my
life have connected me to my past I
think one of the funny because like what
what connected to use your past the
plushies behind you I hate Jews like I
just I think this is so funny like just
sitting in front of your Funko Pop
collection with your plushies behind you
and being like I'm literally Adolf
Hitler's reincarnated body I like it
because Hitler had a creative he had an
artistic spirit and so this guy thinks
that in a modern day this is how it
manifests well if this dude's actually
Hitler we need to get him
I'm sick of these hypotheticals where
it's like would you go back and kill
Baby Hitler he's right here he's back
yeah about him yeah say oh go get on
your meds again you Nutter I've been on
so many meds and none of them have
changed what I saw when I was five so it
didn't yeah so it didn't hit yeah tried
something different keep trying keep
trying
is that guy posting anything new
uh I'd love to explore his hey talk
obsessed so let me uh
get their account pulled up
yes I think I I think like
we're both like
hyper medicalizing uh you know
behavior that would be considered uh out
of the norm
on the one hand and also on the other
hand it's seen as like a way to
to seem different
uh only only kicked into overdrive by
social media clout
and the endless desire to be the center
of attention I would actually like to
ask I want to talk to this guy can we
reach out like I want to know how being
Hitler manifests in his daily life
someone said in the chat that kid told
the Holocaust Survivor sorry for putting
you in a camp there's no he's remorseful
okay no that's actually this is a new
Hitler
chat the chat GPI or GPT whatever of
like uh famous Infamous uh you know
dictators of the past or whatever no oh
there's a okay there's like a history AI
bot and you can like talk to Himmler and
everyone else right Goebbels okay and
they are also remorseful oh they're sad
yeah which is weird it's like no these
people were not remorseful at all why
are you making it seem like that you
know who's not remorseful Osama Bin
Laden no literally when you talk to
Osama Bin Laden he's like no America
deserved 911. which I've I've found that
to be funny as [__] I'm like yeah okay
that's a little bit more realistic the
Nazis are remorseful let's be real so
yeah they're um they may have been
banned recently oh he got banned damn it
it was too good to be true can you guys
try to reach out to him like I genuinely
want to ask him questions they might
have a new account somewhere yeah
um when I search for it I'm seeing lots
of like duets with it but when you click
on the account it just says they got him
[__] oh here here wait okay so okay here
oh this man really dresses like this
I made a new nose ring my five five of
my favorite selfies
a tick tock that goes by the name of
Felix cypher's game mass of traction
after pretending to be The Reincarnation
of German dictator Adolf Hitler
[__] this guy dude apparently he has a
egg kick what the [__] does that mean
yeah that's what I'm trying to find out
he has the egg King I don't know what
that is I don't know not familiar with
that big Lane kink
oh egg laying okay I mean I guess we can
infer that's even weirder than the
Hitler thing what the [__]
plenty of young men think they want to
be Hitler but oh people are actually
trying to ruin his life that's crazy
that she's like yo he doesn't have a job
anymore [__] Nazi scum he's not really
Hitler by the way no but he's like
fantasizing about being Hitler I like
the the Twitter thing is so funny he
probably erased his account then because
people were trying to ruin his life I
don't think this is going to help this
person but I don't know what could
technically help this person I think do
they even want help I don't know
he said here he believes you in Eugenics
just not genocide oh nice okay Hitler
light yeah
yeah it's like early life Hitler I mean
there's a really easy way to have
avoided all of this by just not coming
out and telling the entire world that
you are Hitler so something some people
should stay in the closet yes yeah 100
yeah no coming out party for you if
you're if you're coming out as Hitler
you should just keep that [__] yeah
about Hitler all right let's get on to
some Politics the race to the bottom GOP
primaries it's Trump first DeSantis The
Showdown we've all been waiting for
Trump um
debuted his new nickname for Rod oh so
good meatball Ron [__] so good dude
oh finally he's back baby that and what
he said about Nikki Haley he is so back
oh my king my goat
I still think he's snoozing on deep
State deceptive man he's coming he's
coming after Rihanna he's being a
[__] sassy [__] like he's just he's
going after celebrities again in the
Super Bowl halftime performance and
stuff she looked horrible she looks fat
he's finally he's finally like you know
he's he's taken off the training weights
he get epic fail Rihanna gave without
question the single worst halftime show
in Super Bowl history this after
insulting far more than half of our
nation which is already in serious
decline with her foul and insulting
language also so much for her style what
what is he talking about what was it I
don't know who he's referencing as far
as the stylist thing uh the chop boys
think that this is not actually Trump
but someone else who wrote this because
like Trump doesn't know what epic fail
is which I kind of understand but the
previous for them but the previous
stylist uh jab was actually like
definitely Trump
um but wait what is he talking about
when he says that she insulted she
insulted half the country
uh probably because like she wouldn't
let him use the Trump music or she
wouldn't let her she wouldn't let Trump
use her music in his rallies or
something probably or like you know
shine bright like they're all on their
[__] Donald Trump [__] in like 2016 2017
maybe that's what he's like wait no
talking about here it actually was
something specific and it
uh Rihanna spray painted F Donald Trump
on a car at cardiac a Cadillac Ranch so
he says without her stylist she'd be
nothing bad everything and no talent I
want to talk to her stylist bro she's
made a career of viewing the general
filth while badmouthing America every
chance she gets why is the NFL
showcasing this crap Brianna should not
be the halftime performer yeah it was
pretty funny because like given due to
her uh you know pregnancy status like
her show like her performance was like
super tame and even like Ben Shapiro and
everyone else was like trying to make it
seem like it was immodest but like they
couldn't really do it they were like
grasping for straws everyone was like
fully covered the dancers were yeah and
giant sterile white suits yeah they
couldn't they couldn't really get her on
that so you know now they're like well
it was boring
which is what we want but also not this
time we don't want it to be
so Dawn is going after Ron and he this
is on his uh truth is this truth yeah
he's truthing it he's I'm retrieving all
of these as well are you not on Truth
yet Ethan
to tell you the truth Dan
I'm not on Truth yet what the [__]
where's Rhonda he won't get banned like
on Tick Tock he said I believe in free
speech on truth right Doug Chan Lee
posted here's Ron de sanctimonious
it's funny and so stupid grooming high
school girls with alcohol as a teacher
that's not Ron is it he would never do
such a thing so he's coming after Ron
calling him a groomer and a pedophile
okay saying that he's a pedophile which
by the way
very well might be that is really
[__] weird if you're like 28 wait 30
years old and like hanging out with
[__] high school girls wait what is
the back is that really the true story
of this photo yeah oh that's actually
good he was a teacher he was a teacher
and I think like he was literally
hanging out with like high school that's
really gross at a party where they're
drinking and [__] except here's the
thing okay this is a good line of attack
however
the reality of the situation is that
most people don't think that that's
grooming like conservatives will not
find that to be grooming even though it
literally is weird and it is like more
pedophilic than anything else
conservatives be like whatever they're
[__] hot I was like they're 18 bro no
like no they won't say that as long as
they're 18. these people want child
marriages dude what are you talking
about like oh she's literally on the one
hand being like trans people are you
know destroying society and on the other
hand in the same breath it'll be like a
teenager girl is when she's most viable
to give birth you know the the freaks
they're like actually the [__]
groomer not the queer people uh this is
her stylist actually he's a huge fan of
this guy
Elijah I don't think I don't think
that's who he's talking about when he
says stylist
oh what is he is that some inside
baseball no I don't know maybe ASAP
Rocky
I don't know what the [__] he's on about
but okay that's good dirt I like how
Trump is like he's a sexual predator
folks unlike me yeah there's no I have
done nothing wrong sexually in my whole
life this is how you know the
conservative momentum is losing his
juice and they're turning into like
Hillary supporters in like 2016
basically because
here's what's here's what's really
interesting okay
Bill Mitchell has been popping off and
and a lot of other like Caleb Hall like
all these like conservative commentators
have been popping off at at Donald Trump
saying like I wouldn't be speaking about
grooming if I were you posting photos of
Donald Trump with Jeffrey Epstein and
it's like bro you literally voted for
him twice and you've been defending him
it's awesome are you saying you're
defending a [__] pedophile like
what's the argument you guys like these
photos existed four years ago they're
literally like you sir are a pedophile
and I voted for you twice and I believe
that you're the best thing that's ever
happened in this country and you are
definitely a pedophile this this whole
CL this Clash is going to be so
destructive I can't wait I'm just I mean
it's already starting I'm enjoying it
now so here's the next one
he this guy dong Chan Lee is really
feeding the tea magnanimous de Santa
says he's glad violent Trump protesters
are being arrested he said he hasn't
seen anything specific regarding FBI
warnings about armed mobs marching on
state capitals
uh I don't even know where that's from
that seems like a made-up story but
whatever let's who cares go down
is there more
he's just mad at the scientist
apparently is glad that violent
specifically violent Trump supporters
are being arrested and he said what
about antifa and BLM run
don't you care about them you hypocrite
uh well if so here's another dong Chan
Lee original
Trump's quote tweeting somebody named
Dong Dong Chan Lee with a Pepe yeah I
wish he would do that on Twitter again
[__] man I miss it because you're not
getting enough
jokes on true social like he just he
just keeps choosing to like 5K people
you know Max they'll be back why did
DeSantis vote against Trump's border
wall good question we need explaining
here
Trump said wow if I knew I wouldn't have
endorsed him you didn't know and he
would have had to quit the race down 35
points yeah I mean it is true Trump did
juice uh DeSantis up a lot and DeSantis
did almost lose to Andrew Gillum back in
the day obviously Andrew gillum's
political career unjustifiably was cut
short when he was caught at Fountain
Blue with a gay prostitute and a [__]
load of meth uh you know that's the most
Florida thing you could do okay yeah
he's just a good Florida man yeah I just
like there's nothing wrong with that
whatever let let him have some fun but
um you know Rhonda Sands has almost lost
to him he won by like a margin of a
[__] point so uh you know he's he's
of course significantly more popular now
in Florida
due to copying Trump's STEEZ but
I don't think that will translate to
National prominence now meatball Ron
came that's the new that's the new thing
where did that come from before we get
to this [__] freak yeah uh he
I think uh it was a it was a news story
uh saying that Trump behind closed doors
to allies has been very upset with uh
Ron DeSantis and has been reported as
calling him meatball Ron
but what about meatballs though so
now I love this personally
because like Rhonda Sands is Italian
right oh right yeah it's a little just
and he also kind of looks like a
meatball too yeah which is like exactly
the type of [__] that Trump used to do
really well like you know calling people
fat and stuff even though he himself is
fat like he's very good at that
um and I think meatball Ron is is
excellent marinara Ron over here
um yeah now what I find particularly
funny about this though is that again
conservatives have been saying Bill
Mitchell specifically has been like you
know meatball is an ethnic slur right
and it's like Bro you've lost
it's funny and if your counter to that
is that like ah it's actually an ethnic
slur an anti-italian ethnic slur when uh
you know
the the uh the entire Cuomo uh battle
was like fought over right remember
loofing on him because someone called
him Fredo yeah they Fredo it was an
ethnic slur it's like anti-italian
sentiment like everyone was
understandably laughing at that because
it's [__] hilarious objectively
um getting mad at that and saying that
it's an anti-italian slur is not gonna
not gonna win you any favors so true
actually so here's um man these figures
are unreal this Prophet quote unquote is
starting to gravitate towards Ron
DeSantis these are people who would were
hardcore Trump supporters back
before uh this guy Charlie shamp claims
he received a vision several years ago
revealing DeSantis is the ultimate
future is to have a position his
ultimate future is to have a position in
the United States as president so this
guy had a vision why didn't he say it
beforehand then
if he had a vision a long time ago
come on son so obvious so by the way he
didn't want to disrupt the flow of time
obviously yeah so these are these guys
here this is a famous guy I forget his
name but Jim Baker okay so he was a
hardcore Trump supporter he's a Y2K
Pastor too long also he has a has slop
bucket on his [__] yeah they're
they're all like they're all like our
slot bucket
they're all apocalypse Preppers so of
course like they're constantly talking
about how the apocalypse is nigh and
then uh you know what a wonderful way to
make money off of that
God damn it by selling [__] slot
buckets
hold on one sec here so apparently we
have some info and meatball Ron
um it seems Trump just said it to the
New York Times and then it just became a
thing
that's kind of cool I like the meatball
thing pretty good
yeah this is his appearance apparently
yes so here is this guy this also was
one of the guys who was selling silver
solution during covet and got sued by
the I think it was the FTC that stopped
them yeah which because it's the nanny
State I mean what the [__]
you should be able to get uh you should
be able to poison your audience bro I
have this sawdust that will cure cancer
straight up
okay here he is talking about the we
need to walk this is not a serious
person just look at his [__] fade
look at his whoa that's that's Auntie
Mena that is literally that is the most
meta haircut okay
dude [__] dude every Arab every Arab
teenager all the way to like the age of
38 has this exact same fade okay so what
is it then it's is it the beard you put
like it's like two plastic things that
you put on your face that the [__]
guy shapes up with okay this man looks
like a [__] we have you have just you
have just made fun of every Indian guy
and every Arab guy on the planet no I
have not this is this also could this is
like it's the Israeli [__] have
this haircut no it's the beard what is
going on with the beard the beard and
the haircut
it's a double feature what do you mean
what's what's up with the beard the
beard does not go along the beard and
the haircut go together
okay listen this man took mascara and
painted on this beard and thought we
wouldn't notice like it's crazy he's
literally white Hassan minhaj
sorry your district is not on that level
no I didn't say myself I said Hassan
minhan oh sorry I thought I'll Hustle No
I don't have that I don't have that
Hassan minhaj though but yeah kind of
yeah there's just a subtle difference in
the beard Darkness it's this is the best
I love this [__] I I love this beard
fade combo it's so you're you're like an
Arab [__] boy did they introduce him as
Prophet Charlie sham they put respect on
his name boy yeah God should have told
him not to get that fade honestly
there was Jesus there was Moses and then
there was prophet Charlie shamp living
prophet
where I saw two palm trees and I saw one
of them was planted in California the
other one in Florida and I said Lord
what is this these two palm trees he
said this palm tree from California is
Ronald Reagan this palm tree that is in
Florida is Ron DeSantis he said Rhonda
everybody God loves but he said who the
[__] is Ron DeSantis because this was
years ago
like I don't know who the [__] that is
Lord just trust me remember this name
the Lord the god sounds like a hillbilly
remember his name wrong DeSantis you see
this here palm tree here
nice weather out there in Florida
California like
I'd like to nominate one of these
Bible Belt but they just too dumb boy we
need to go out to them lower to
California
or Ronald DeSantis Ronald is the second
has an anointing Ronald DeSantis
it's a holy name Ronald
just like McDonald you know he Ronald
McDonald was said to be the first modern
prophet
dude and I saw huh uh Ron DeSantis as a
as a tree of righteousness that palm
tree and I saw it uprooted from Florida
and brought to Washington DC wow and
planted in Washington D.C and as the
storms came he was not moved that's
right that's right about Ron DeSantis
that we need to begin to pray for we
need to begin to look at because his
ultimate future is to have a position in
the United States as the president and
be planted in Washington DC and he would
be like a Ronald Reagan yeah
I just want to say one thing before we
talk about how [__] psychotic this is
uh because like I mean this is like
you're you're creating like
you have millions of people that watch
this and believe it which is no millions
of people watch Jim Baker
dude these guys have like insane
followings not just Jim Baker but like
this kind of [__] is not a small
Audience by any means tell evangelists
have major networks where does Jim Baker
broadcast like where do people watch
this
um I don't know I I don't know where Jim
Baker specifically broadcasted can you
guys get some details on like his
audience I'm just I'm genuinely curious
um I don't know where Jim Baker
specifically broadcast but a lot of
these guys have like AM radio shows like
it's like Alex Jones people think Alex
Jones has like a tiny audience because
they don't realize how big his audience
actually is because he has like AM radio
shows that reach millions of people that
are broadcasted to like millions and
millions of people on their [__]
daily commutes and [__]
yeah I mean but at the minute you have a
dude with this beard line on you lost
well my point was going to be that the
guy he's like you know hyping up both
Ronald Reagan and Ron DeSantis like
they're conservative right but Ronald
Reagan is like a Hollywood lib okay that
turned into a a super racist uh
neoliberal uh devil man but like Ron
DeSantis is a Yale and Harvard Law
graduate you know what I mean he went to
Yale in Harvard Law he was a Navy
officer like the absolute worst most
despicable [__] career choices you
could make and like things that these
people should normally hate you know
what I mean
yeah he's a super like cultural Elite
yeah he went to the Gavey and became any
and Not only was he like a a Navy person
but like he was an officer too which is
you know ugh so here it says Jim Baker
shows broadcast throughout the United
States Canada and the entire world
through multiple broadcasts on DirecTV
Dish Network and Roku
holy [__] well is there any stats on his
viewership
I've been looking to I'm not seeing many
stats but um I mean I he's on TV he's on
TV and like Hassan said uh these
televangelists they have big audiences
so that that is [__] really scary
that is really really really scary
well they're insane that they're like
this is this kind of unhinged commentary
has a a wide audience and it's like
it's not just like laughed out of every
room and the Republican Party does kind
of capitulate to this kind of extremist
uh attitude well I see what I see is a
very intentional move to start moving
public perception and support to
DeSantis they're coming they're rallying
behind the census so this is going to be
so [__] interesting to see this Clash
here's Charlie sham by the way he is if
you guys were questioning his
credentials I'll have you know he has
uh with pinpoint accuracy presidential
elections catastrophic natural disasters
revealing government Corruptions and
exposing terrorism plots what the [__]
yeah he he knows what the [__] he's he's
like he they call him a prophet like he
legit is they say he's like legitimately
a prophet you think a prophet would have
a better website just saying you think a
prophet would have a better [__] uh
beer and hair routine
about let's read about Charlie I love
Charlie
is awesome
let's see he has been commissioned by
Heaven as a prophet to bring healing and
Revival into the Nations I'm here to
bring healing and Revival to All Nations
this gay people are you going to hell
but all people in all nations the Jews
are definitely going to hell but you
anyway all healing and Revival
that's it huh okay well there he is the
prophet ladies and gentlemen you know
Squarespace as website foreign
here's a video of him healing crippled
people
uh and watch the raw power of God
manifest by the power
[Music]
of the tiger
tonight in the mighty name of Jesus
Christ
I had a dream low one palm tree in
California
upon your knees shit's so sad bro in the
name of Jesus rise up and walk right now
rise up and walk walk in the name of
Jesus this man can do it all in the name
of Jesus
the power of God
[Music]
you know you never get a follow-up with
these people who are miraculously cured
by these preachers like I want to see
the next day that they're walking you
know her ass is back in that wheelchair
sore as hell yeah like let's get a week
you know for that moment Jesus cured her
yeah
Amen brother
this there was a [__] palm tree in
Florida I tell you Mane this should be
had all kinds of coconuts this just like
makes me sad when I see stuff like this
it's just so many people who have just
been duped yeah they're just they're
taking all the these poor people they
just they're already not rich and then
you have more con men that just come in
and basically like turn them upside down
and shake them out for whatever's left
so that's our boy there uh
Charlie champ good man there good man
Nikki Haley is officially in the race
who the [__] that or again
she's running for president watch out
this is
how dare you should I start this over
yes please timestamp no I time stamped
it to kind of the close her closing
sales pitch because it's a long video
and it's just it she's just another
Trump Republican basically what's he's
an Indian woman what's the like ratio
uh it's quite bad is that plug-ins don't
I put it on your computer so you could
see but I guess it's not working I don't
see it
um
it is
uh 300 likes to 2 000 likes she was the
she was the governor of South Carolina
from 2011 to 2017 which she mentions
there and uh you know her becoming the
governor of South Carolina proves that
South Carolina is not racist even though
her name is Nikki Haley and uh you know
she I did not know that she was Indian
until she like uh came out of the gate
Swinging with the with the I thought she
was half Indian when you say Indian like
like no not Native American yeah no like
okay out of India okay great okay
and uh you know that like her her
personally whitewashing herself in an
effort to you know be more appealing to
a broader audience uh does not factor
into this consideration but
um anyway regardless
she was the first female governor of
Asian American Heritage okay we love
that so there's that she's a girl boss
yes
um she became the first indian-american
member of presidential cabinet okay
and she was a United States ambassador
to the UN from 2017 to 2018
quite credentials and confirming to the
U.S Senate
and um
uh yeah she was she was aggro on North
Korean missile tests and stuff like that
well let's see her pitch maybe she's a
viable candidate against Trump and
DeSantis let's see yeah here it is and
when evil did come right police in South
Carolina are looking for a gunman
following a shooting at a church several
victims we don't know the uh severity we
turned away from Fear toward God and the
values that still make our country the
freest and greatest in the world
we must turn in that direction again
Republicans have lost the popular vote
in seven years straight up trying to
sell me a reverse mortgage right now bro
it's so funny that she says Republicans
have lost the popular vote in seven of
the last eight elections it's just
you're not supposed to say that and then
she's like and I'm and I'm trying to
make that I'm trying to make that record
uh even worse that's right this isn't my
first rodeo I love that I love that for
her
change yeah you're gonna be positive Joe
Biden's record is abysmal but that
shouldn't come as a surprise the
Washington establishment has failed us
over and over and over again
it's time for a new generation of
leadership Ken to ReDiscover fiscal
responsibility
secure our border and strengthen I
wonder who she's trying to get to vote
for her
white people I trust him old ass [__]
white business owners yeah white people
country white people or pride and our
purpose
she does not have the juice some people
look at America and see vulnerability
the Socialists left sees an opportunity
to rewrite history
China and Russia are on the March they
all think we can be bullied kicked
around
you should know this about me
I don't put up with bullies and when you
kick back it hurts them more if you're
wearing heels
and I'm running for president
what happened like I feel like somewhere
along the line I mean I've said this so
many times at this point But like
everyone becomes a liberal in a long
enough timeline and that is like
is this like Hillary Clinton running for
president what the [__] do you mean oh
it's better when you have heels on like
who are you trying to appeal to in the
Republican Party
when you say that
she was wearing a palm tree pen I don't
know if you noticed that is that's isn't
that the South Carolina uh it's not on
the phone or something well I don't know
but but maybe champ misinterpreted the
uh he was seeing palm trees in his
vision so maybe you should cut back on
the criticism is it not the South
Carolina flag though uh I I don't yeah
it is yeah yeah she's wearing the South
Carolina flag he's the Crescent in the
in the tree
actually I want to move on to Roseanne
oh you want to go back to not well one
one thing we have to mention no no
before you do that before you do that
before you do that before we get to
Comedy yeah
and how the right is defending it thank
God because it's under attack finally uh
let's take a look at what the real
comedian of the right the only comedian
of the right Donald Trump had to say
about Nikki Haley do you have that I do
yeah yeah Trump posted on social about
uh his Queen absolutely [__]
destroyed her dude holy [__] hey hold on
Nikki Haley is like I love the I love
the Republican party and you know these
these Elite monsters looking at like
Kamala Harris and being like you know
what we should have our own Kamala
Harris but this time you know make her
white passing uh hmm just equally as
boring just no Charisma whatsoever going
to lose in even South Carolina yeah it's
not loading for some reason but it's
true social down conditions on my I
think
had a hard time making the decision to
run for president because she's very
publicly stated that she would never run
against the president he did a great job
and who was the best president in my
lifetime I told Nikki to follow her
heart not her ambition or belief who
knows stranger things have happened
she's pulling at one percent not a bad
start absolute daggers I mean it's so
good and right he's right he is right
Nikki Haley does not have the juice
she doesn't
so anyway here Tucker Carlson thank God
is putting together a documentary about
the death of comedy and uh they brought
the big guns out they got Roseanne out
to do a set and you know yeah I love I
love announcing the death of comedy by
liberals and then like having Roseanne
be the defender of Comedy when she's
like single-handedly murdering comedy
herself well here hold on hold on every
time she tries to be funny you want to
play Roseanne first so before we even
watch that Fox News who's saying
comedy's dead put out this preview of
Roseanne Barr cancel this wow that's
such an original concept yeah no I've
never seen I've never heard that before
the first comedian to ever make fun of
that concept so here here's a preview of
uh this is not even remotely hacky this
is this is trigger warning everybody
because comedy is about to happen Okay
thank you the most offensive thing
you've ever seen yeah so it literally is
though it is [__] offensive but not
in the way that like oh I'm so triggered
by her words like I'm just I'm angry
when I see this stuff I have a visceral
reaction to this because it's just so
painfully unfunny well here is the
rebirth of Comedy a son uh Roseanne Barr
yeah like 65 year old psychotic woman
wearing pigtails
[Music]
not looking at me for myself
why is she trying to do like a lolly
with the is that the anime where like
the young girls she's doing a lawly guys
with the pic okay I think that was her
intention never mind
one night only thank God they Limited
she's so goofy with it
yes look at the audience
we love you Queen wait till you hear the
joke
yes a 200 seat Auditorium thank you you
very much hi I'm gonna perish I'm gonna
perish I'm gonna die if I oh God
cancel this privilege it is for you to
have me here this evening ladies and
gentlemen yes
yes
Mom this is the fire there we go
hold on here's the build up
it's about to drop a bomb right now yeah
I guess they thought they shut me up but
guess what
anyway
well she doesn't have jokes
you know what I you know what I think
this is just like an hour of
psychobabble and they would this is the
only coherent moment they could use for
a trailer bro she made Steven Crowder
look like a viable stand-up oh yeah you
know how like Temple has those other
guys that are like objectively dumber
than he is on a show to make himself
look like a normal person okay I feel
like this is a psyop by the right to be
like Stephen Crowder's a comedian look
if Roseanne Barr's a comedian so was
Stephen Crowder
who's that one comedian that's just
touring everyone he just screams he's
from uh Jim Brewer yeah he's my fave
he's oh funny
[Applause]
yes ma'am I love that we just hold on
they couldn't shut me up
you forgot what she was doing I said
that the producer looked like an ape and
I stand by it oh is that what she said
well that's what she got fired for right
not the producer it was an Obama advisor
oh well okay well somebody that [__]
was why yeah oh my God I forgot about
that that was from that yeah
okay that's kind of funny
wait for all I think that was when she
was on Rogan afterwards right yeah her
having like a psychotic meltdown is is
pretty funny never mind she made like a
she made like a bit out of it like
that's where those sound bites are got
it okay wait did that win that must have
done well in the soundbite Olympics in
that year that was before my time dude
that was that was the first year of the
podcast pre-zack really yeah yeah it was
like yeah it was before my time wow
we're gonna get really offended if I do
not offend everybody where are my people
you have not even set a single joke I
mean it's offensive that like you
charged money to have people listen to
this someone in the chat said that ozam
pick face though and that's a excellent
joke chatter good job
old person medicine the no it's the
[__] it's the diabetes medication
that people are shooting up with so they
can lose weight it's an appetite
suppressant I'll take some of that
foreign
I've always been upset at like look I I
love comedy uh I've been a defender of
Comedy 90 of the time on my stream I'm
like having to describe what jokes are
and why you should be able to laugh to
like leftist people you know what I mean
it's like a big part of my stream
unfortunately okay
and as a fan of Comedy I've always been
frustrated with like the Ted Talk style
approach like the Hannah Gatsby's of the
world on the left there's a lot of like
liberal comedians who basically try to
undermine the basics of comedy by saying
like comedy is actually a bad thing or
whatever right
and then this is the the right wing
version of that where you're just
expecting claps
for um an audience that agrees with you
you're not like you're not like touching
on uh you know the the Bro forget these
hypocrisies or anything like that you
just said a single [__] thing yeah I
mean she hasn't even done that yet but
I'm saying like Dave Chappelle and
Hannah Gatsby Dave Chappelle's like
newer sets when he's talking about trans
issues and Hannah Gatsby talking about
how comedy is immoral is basically in
the same wavelength this is even worse
than that somehow
but it is it is it is destroying the the
very notion of why uh comedy exists to
begin with I mean this is practically a
Tim and Eric sketch right now where it
just switches between the audience
there you are don't worry I'm gonna get
him I mean it pretty much
Tim heideker's stand-up special itself
right the anti all the anti joke yeah
it just right
anyways anybody else been fired recently
I think about it
it wasn't recent that was six years ago
you need a new job
six years ago Dude literally not one
joke was featured and they had this
super big ass [__] like beat drop for
that one too I thought she's about to
say a joke well they're well the other
video has some actual jokes yeah can we
see the actual jokes on the set because
like the actual jokes on the set are
even [__] worse not the Tucker
Carlson one there's another one there's
a one minute preview of uh no no it was
longer there's like a yeah there's like
a two minute I think oh by the way Benny
Johnson the host of the left can't meme
a guy who definitely knows comedy Legend
uh tweet it out uh comedian Roseanne
Barr is back baby famous famous not gay
Benny Johnson uh wondering once again
why there are so many gay cruise ads on
his uh
on his computer right why are the gay
cruises targeting me Benny Johnson says
I don't know they follow me wherever I
go yeah
ask no questions have nothing to do with
the real world what is my gender mom
what is my gender your gender is get a
job that's your gender [__] yes
yes
she she can't but she did and they can't
fire her now she can't be fired by
anybody is she allowed is she allowed to
do that she's not but she can't be fired
because she's on Fox Nation bro
I'm so dude you don't understand how
triggered I am right now dude
she's actually what's I appreciate is
the first comedian to make jokes about
pronouns like that dude I know dude
that's why it's like Cutting Edge it's
Cutting Edge when Dave Chappelle does it
too when he's like uh LOL attack
helicopter
have nothing to do with the real world
what is my gender mom
what is my gender your gender is get a
job that's your gender dude oh thank God
you play that again he said it
she said it
what is a woman they don't know that
nope that one they're asking all the
time what is a woman
yeah no one is asking that's literally
Matt literally not a single person it's
like what is a woman what is a woman
somebody tells me yeah that's that's
just Matt Walsh because he's like you
know is my wife a woman he's trying to
not get in legal trouble but like you
know
that's why he's asking
right time what is a woman I'll tell you
what a woman is a woman is me
whoa
that was [__] crazy big laugh that's
actually interesting because it's hard
to tell uh she looks I mean
she looks like they they they put a
laugh track on this after enough
medicine and [__] they they put a
laugh track on this 100 100 P okay those
people are stoked yeah you think they're
just going that's crazy that is a woman
you're right you're right brother so so
what is she so what's the joke right she
says a woman is me
are you trying to deconstruct this right
now because there's no joke the joke I
agree with her I'm sure liberals if they
could hear this right now hypothetically
would be screaming because they're so
angry theoretically I think the joke
would make more sense if she if people
thought she was a man
so she's like I mean yes yeah the
juxtaposition would make it funny but
like it doesn't matter because I'm
telling you Ethan there is no comedy
here the comedy comes from the the
Liberals that they are imagining in
their minds listening to the set and
getting very angry because it like
shakes their world view
that's what they're laughing at the the
hypothetical libs that are being owned
so a woman is me so what's the offensive
thing there is she just saying it she's
willing to say it yeah yeah because like
in their minds it's like women don't
exist Libs think women right you're not
you're actually not allowed to say I am
a woman don't say anymore this is like
dystopian comedy in like 1984 it's just
playing endlessly on the TV and
everyone's like
how to pretend to laugh otherwise they
get arrested for some sub version
so this is fired
and by the way this is the premium jokes
that they put together that one they're
asking all the time what is a woman I'll
tell you what a woman is a woman
it's me
it's harder even the second time
I'm getting progressively triggered I'm
still pissed right now [__] man if you
ever [__] say the W word to me yeah I
I hate women I I think there's only one
gender man that's it
that's that's what I believe well man do
I need to explain it yeah exactly it's
in the name hello
woman is okay
a woman is someone who cleans up
everybody else's
that's what a woman is oh well trans
women can do that so that's actually
pretty woke of her okay that's the
gender roles I'm [__] pissed I don't
even understand she's saying like a
woman cleans up everyone's [__] like
okay yeah woman cleans up after
everything okay fine let's let's Epic
but that that cannot be her story her
life is a story of her ruining
everything and people cleaning up her
mess okay let her cook let her cook I
want to hear we're ruining her a bit she
literally got fired for getting so
[__] up on Ambien that she was doing
like racial slurs on Twitter like you
not cleaning up anyone's mess she's a
man this woman is a man
foreign
and that's on God
a woman is somebody whose boobs hang
down to her knees with a prolapsed
uterus from giving birth the five
ungrateful little privileges never had
to work for anything in their whole damn
life I think she forgot the starting
point of this joke
yeah I don't really she just kind of
like
I did think that was funny I like the
saggy tits and the prolapsed vagina as
an image I think that's powerful yeah
why did she say that
she's a we're a woman real woman's
vaginas go down to their ankles yeah
real women are moms that hate their kids
that's right real women can tuck them
titties up their vagina
who resent their own children that's
right a real woman okay that one was
like a little confusing for me because
real women I don't even understand where
she's going with that but let's see
maybe she has a maybe she has an end
point to this okay let's head down to
her knees with a prolapsed uterus from
giving birth to five ungrateful little
privilege never had to work for anything
in their whole damn life I mean yeah
sure children are privileged yeah just
saying I hate my kids she started with
like you can't cancel me woke left I
hate my kids yeah I mean that's like
this is old school comedy though it's
like my [__] ass wife want to kill her
like that that sort of thing right so I
guess she's doing a shout out to the old
Comics
perspective he's old yeah yeah real
women
could throw their prolapsed vagina over
their shoulder
alongside their saggy tits okay that's
right real women can play jump rope with
their titties well I want to see I want
to see what else you got let's see come
on
I want I wanted to deliver this epic
final note
my pronouns are kiss my
no she did not
she did not I I don't know if I'm I
don't know if I'm fuming or just shocked
or I I just I've never seen that joke
before I've never seen that though you
mean
wait it's The wow the the same joke that
she made in the beginning so that you
heard it twice technically in the set no
she said kiss my ass well she also
started off with another pronoun joke if
you remember didn't she she did it's
very forgettable okay well she's the
first one and this a comedy set to ever
make that joke about pronouns yeah what
did she say what was it my pronouns are
prolapsed vagina the first pro the first
the first uh pronoun joke was about what
the kids pronoun is which is get a job
so their gender is get a job I never
heard that yes
I love that you could say anything after
pronouns it doesn't have to be a pronoun
actually yeah my pronoun is
jump rope over my swinging these guys
are like incredibly woke they're like
they're like [__] like Tumblr kids
basically you know what I mean kids that
like grow up on Tumblr where they're
they're uh you know advocating for the
complete abolition of gender by uh
advocating for like you know
what is it what are they what are they
called Xeno genders or whatever what
[__] uh or Demi or I know what you're
talking about what is that there's like
Neo pronouns there she's advocating well
not she I don't know what Neil pronoun
geta I don't think Getta is advocating
for
Neo pronouns my pronouns are pick up
McDonald's on the way home
today my pronouns are
I'm watching below deck tonight till
about 10 p.m then I'm getting in bed
wake up early tomorrow
[Applause]
my pronouns are
I respect her for well I respect Guetta
for a abolishing gender it's awesome
it's good good forget it good for job
he's a good man get a job no not me it's
a okay she's get a get a is a good man
she's a good man is a good job and just
just to show you how [__] bankrupt
I I really think God is a good lady
you're doing it again stop you're you're
not you're not freaking get his pronouns
yes I am okay Benny Johnson who is a
self-proclaimed comedian who has paid to
produce content by right-wing
establishments literally said
that this [__] is hilarious my pronouns
are kiss my ass dying laughing emoji
now that's fun that is unintentionally
uh you know Johnson unintentionally
hilarious
Benny Johnson goes yo the advertising on
Military times right now
bro it's also what's gator the crew's ad
or hidden he's on Military times
[Music]
dude big lard the world's largest gay
cruise
yeah what is he looking at my pronouns
are get on board of the gay cruise my
pronouns are nice abs buddy you want to
come into my room later uh I've got some
math week but listen listen while while
Roseanne Barr is defending the sanctity
of comedy and you know because it is
illegal if we see you if we catch you
laughing we will throw you in the gulag
yes um there's also uh another man who's
also defending comedy Tucker Carlson yes
objectively a hilarious person who
definitely knows the joy of laughter uh
let's take a look on how Tucker Carlson
is defending uh comedy nothing funnier
than a dude that wears a bow tie I mean
he is funny looking yes
this is literally the [__] face
of white privileged nepotism baby with
the he's like Richie Rich grown up yeah
sexual fantasy so gooey so let's let's
look at what he had to do he's like he's
like inbred did a whole documentary
saving comedy yeah so here it is so
that's the lead up uh this is all part
the Roseanne thing and this documentary
and I got I got something to say about
some of the comedians featured on this
in a little bit after we watch it
oh did you have the guy who was
complaining that they used his clip all
of them complained everyone that's not
featured in the documentary that was
used as a clip were like dude [__] you
you [__] racist piece of [__] like we
the [__] are you talking about spoiler
alert Ethan you're spoiling it boiler
he's gonna do a big reveal of that in a
second just play it
you're telling me just play it Hassan
yeah who are you I know but just you
know I proud my pronouns are just play
it okay well dude but just play it tell
me what are your pronouns please play it
of a free Society
it's basically you want to say comedy
illegal oh no offensive comedian we're
just trying to make people laugh
okay sorry I can't I can't free speeches
first of all Elon Musk a dude whose
comedy is literally just [__]
reposting memes from 9gag is it a
documentary explaining what real
comments well I think Source Babylon B I
don't think Elon is in this documentary
I think Ari on the other hand is dude
like Ari shafir is which by the way your
career said washed bro Washed by the way
he reached out to be on the podcast
recently really I said [__] no or oh his
manager [__] probably not it's
probably not good etiquette to say that
no but I said [__] that hold this
[__] Lorry God damn it Go suckle on
Joe Rogan's steroid nipples more you
[__] I'm so [__] subversive uh she
manages more than just Arya oh and she's
awesome I love her I just don't like art
um yeah she's great I just don't like
art them pitches coming just sorry just
better people respectful past I'm sorry
if you have better people than Ari I'd
be interested right because this is
washed up as it gets my friends if he
went on Tucker Carlson if he actually if
this isn't just like offensive if this
is legitimately him participate
participating in the documentary he is
Omega washed I'm lore 98 sure that's the
case because there's another clip I saw
with a extended like part of the
internet
comedian we're just trying trying to
make people laugh well I'm just trying
to make people laugh
I mean what the heck doesn't Ari have a
bit where he like went into like a black
neighbor and screamed the n-word
I don't know but that sounds like
something he would do I don't know
if that's the case can you can you
factor but yes he does a lot of uh shock
comedy stuff I know he is probably most
famous outside of Comedy circles for
being the guy that whenever somebody
beloved dies he always pops off with a
bunch of tweets about what a piece of
[__] they are and how he's glad they're
dead or whatever
you do though like that's like actually
sjw [__] it is so what happened you're
just like you know adopting the tactics
of the people who want to destroy comedy
like [__] no I think he I think he's
trying to be brave right he's just gonna
like be counter you do this I know this
I want to be funny too okay and I'm not
a very funny person you do this oh stop
you're very funny you do this Outreach
[__] when you have no other bits you
don't have like a clever bit you don't
have a clever way to like analyze the
situation so you're just going for
outrage laughter and you know we all do
it sometimes Ethan me no I've never you
would never do that I I've done it as
well I understand it it's just that like
it's just you can't make that your whole
shtick like it's just so whack all right
let's see
play the rest of the artist any
offensive comedian we're just trying to
make people laugh
there is a fear of getting canceled who
are you nobody can Adam's one of the
biggest right-wing [__] back Adam
Carolla yeah another guy who wanted to
come on the show I just said [__] off
too so brave so they're they're showing
people getting like punched on stage and
stuff we which uh like as though there's
like systemic attacks against comedians
like comedians are being targeted which
you know I uh I think it's like
ridiculous to [__] punch an
Entertainer on stage it's like no
everybody thinks it's crazy everyone
understands that everyone recognizes
that like you know and the people that
think that that's uh acceptable they're
irrelevant they're like you know people
chirping on Twitter who gives them well
and then the ultimate irony is most of
the comedians they're featured here as
the brave uh comedy Warriors
have responded to this by saying you
don't have my permission you are racist
[__] pieces of [__] don't use my [__]
even even Dave Chappelle who is like
very transphobic I don't think he would
be on board with like whatever the [__]
Tucker Carlson is saying no like because
no he wouldn't be I mean we'll we'll see
maybe he'll come out and and make a
statement or something like that but I
mean this is a great opportunity for him
to make something funny out of this
situation but
um yeah let's see well I don't know if
you knew this but comedians are actually
the um
most oppressed group in society right
now yeah yeah this is a can I can show
this right yeah here's um
here is uh
Ari
shame to the Jews uh Safari what's his
name I don't know
Ari shame to the Jews of fear he did had
a bit the amazing races where he would
drive around black neighborhoods like
this
I'm just trying to make people laugh no
it's funny it's it's objectively it's
just why were they angry see how angry
they get
yeah they're mine
oh wow yeah people are not like that was
dope but well some people actually are
saying that about I just I thought that
it was like not that big of a deal when
it happened especially because the two
both of those people involved Will Smith
uh and Chris Rock are both you know
they're they've known each other for 35
[__] years and they're both comedians
you know what I mean
I guess it was uh he's not he's a
musician and uh actor
rewind
you know they know each other no but the
the the uh I don't know which one this
is what is that I don't know yeah it
happens all the time and here's the
thing you know they act like it's some
coordinated effort by libs that we could
like destroy and yeah comedy we sit in
the nightclubs we watch him for we're
policing for him to cross the line and
then we attack baby
nobody can Jimmy Lee is the only Jimmy
Lee needs to be featured in this [__]
documentary all right let's see let's
see what else I want to see Adam Kroll
is a giant piece of [__] too by the way
nobody can stop their mind
oh wow
you know what's not funny one [__]
sanctimonious nobody can speak there
nobody nobody thinks it's funny when you
got like a bunch of Rich old white dudes
[__] constantly mouthing off about
how difficult it is that people are not
laughing at their same [__] hacky
bits over and over again
please laugh you you see [__]
yell at Bill Burr no because he's
[__] funny okay just shut the [__] up
and be funny okay that's the job that
you have comedians are not like uh you
know the modern philosophers or whatever
the [__] okay they can oftentimes
successfully make cultural critique that
is objectively funny show the
disparities show the contradictions in a
humorous way and comedy can be
educational in that regard comedy can
also uh teach people the the uh personal
lived experiences of uh of marginalized
communities like I love comedy okay it's
important for me this man asked upload a
video called offering black people free
trips back to Africa racist prank gone
wrong
um he has a a specific uh interest in
offending black people I noticed he has
a whole series of this Amazing Racist
with uh teaching agents to drive a bunch
of other different races does he do any
Jewish jokes I mean yeah he does he does
yeah I'm sure he does it's good for you
all right
equal opportunity you're a good man
why are people offended is this man skin
exposed
is that like just his [__] dick area
like is he wearing shoes what the [__]
what is that outfit bro all right all
right let's let's uh I want to watch the
rest of this clip uh because there's
there's all right here there's some good
juicy stuff in there yeah by the way um
they go nobody can speak their mind in
this one hour documentary airing on the
most popular Network on television
the one thing that people probably
Empower can't stand is being made fun of
right play by their rules right I
couldn't be able to say certain things
on YouTube you're not gonna be able to
see certain things on iTunes is that
comedy boy this what a disaster this is
right now it is now I'm not giving a TED
Talk my job is to be funny you're such a
huge loser dude dude if you if you are a
comedian and you went on the Tucker
Carlson documentary about how comedy's
dying you're washed there's no you're so
[__] washed you're so mad that like
[__] aren't lavender your jokes
anymore you've lost the sauce that's it
your pronouns are [__] washed up and
I'm not talking about the people whose
clips that they use I'm not talking
about the comics like the first guy that
they showed is uh is a young black
comedian uh who who actually was in the
right for yelling at the Heckler I know
and did a really good job of like
dismantling the Heckler who was
immediately kicked out okay and there
are situations like that that he that
Tucker Carlson put in his uh in his
documentary I guess and and will
participating so far I've identified I
think three
Ari Corolla and this [__] little rat
weasel like out of all the people that
they showed you know regardless of what
they've done personally like yeah Louis
CK is probably like one of the only
funny people uh or was funny and is no
longer I think he also he's not a
conservative [__] bag yeah well yeah
like showing his dick to people yeah
exactly you know is that I guess that is
kind of a conservative yeah I mean
attribute
on stage Communists are supposed to show
where these
door let's go
my pronouns are Jimmy Dore he's [__]
he is oh God he and that's that's a
funny guy right there
The Narrative is wrong and then one girl
goes we think you're not entitled to be
making some of the jokes you're making
this is the current state of Comedy
Tucker Carlson Originals the death of
Comedy so the guy that they showed the
the Indian dude that they showed at the
end he also I think he's like writes for
SNL and stuff too like he should yeah he
[__] on being used in this regard I just
liked it yeah nimesh Patel so here's the
guy uh yeah here he is he says this is
nonsense comedy is thriving there was a
reason I didn't do Tucker back in 2018
no one hears a martyr for comedy
everyone featured in this trailer
selling out theaters and making money
myself included stop this fake victim BS
that guy was in the trailer yeah and the
other guy the first guy also had
something to say as well his was really
funny what was his response
um also his name I was trying to find it
I love how they're dissing The Loser
comedians that were in this documentary
I mean he's saying everyone features in
his trailer selling out theaters and
making money I doubt it okay some of the
some of the people that are featured are
uh you know without their permission but
maybe some of the others not necessarily
thriving as hard or maybe they are I
don't know maybe there is genuinely an
audience of like unfunny divorced dads
who [__] really want to hear someone
talk about how woke these uh libtards
are over and over again a Roseanne's
audience man yeah I was crushing yeah if
you guys find his tweet this guy's it
was it was it was good
in the meantime the other guy is Troy
Bond I'm pretty sure if you want to find
his tweet
um I think actually you may not know
this but but Ted Cruz actually
I thought that was the first time yeah
Troy bond is the other guy Troy has
Ebola is his yeah it's his pin tweet go
to
Troy has Ebola on Twitter
got it
he says Hey Tucker Carlson go [__] a
green Eminem you open mouth the [__]
it's funny that you are making a
documentary about comedy considering the
right wing has no idea how to do it you
use my clip without permission and I
will now be joining antifa in
retaliation
yeah you got the The non-hacky Comedians
are all like dude why are you doing this
yeah documentary someone responders it's
funny because he showed your clip of
what is likely exerted a woman getting
mad at over your s t or joke about a
conservative yeah yeah and he said
because I remember yeah he was like the
really funny part is the joke she was
interrupting was a joke where I said it
was the most Anti was the most pro-anti
Trump comedian
um
and uh you know
so it was literally a conservative that
got offended yeah oh for sure no
actually no no it wasn't she was saying
he's racist he actually wasn't I
remember yeah he's um I think Troy is
he's like in quarter black or half black
I'm not entirely sure I remember like
reading up about him in the when when
that came out I was celebrating
Roseanne's brilliant comedy but it turns
out she may have stolen her joke bro you
know what this is okay this is just like
what Elon Musk was saying uh originally
everyone was like Elon Musk is a free
speech Defender and we were like no he's
not and everyone was like shut the [__]
up yes he is that's why I wanted to buy
Twitter and we were like no he doesn't
want that he just wants you to [__]
admire him and look where we're at
months later like Twitter has exploded
the trending tab doesn't [__] work
Twitter barely [__] works half the
goddamn time and he's firing Engineers
who keep telling him like yeah your
engagement is like lower than it was
before because people don't really care
about your nine gag memes and he
basically is like trying to reconfigure
the platform's algorithm to only serve
Elon Musk tweets and that's at the heart
of this that's not a joke this is not
actually yeah that's a real thing that's
happening and he was never a free speech
guy if you can can you paste that story
here these these people do not care
about Free Speech they just think free
speech is when you like have to sit
there and laugh at what the [__] they're
saying that's their gripe their gripe is
not being liked by a a broader audience
of liberals that's why like it went from
Comedy is you know comedy is being
silenced you're not allowing me to like
make jokes and there was like uh in the
most heated time in like the in the at
the final stages of the Obama era there
certainly was a wave of people that were
just like literally filming comedians
that were trying out their bits their
new material into being like look at our
races there's new materials it's like yo
that's how [__] Comedy Works you have
to try your [__] and sometimes it's not
gonna land and if you're talking about
tricky issues if you're talking about
like you know delicate matters if it
bombs you're going to look like a
[__] [__] but then when you look
like a [__] [__] you never do it
again or you rehash your bit you you
work on it you're defending me bro yeah
and the point is exactly the point is
like there was a there was at least like
kind of movement but most people don't
give a [__] about it in the real world
right but these guys are still riding
the wave of like uh trying to counter
that by being like no no no you're not
letting me be funny it's like you're
just not funny dude you're not funny
it's not comedy is not dying you're
murdering comedy by being just unfunny
and constantly [__] complaining from
a privileged position about how like
people are not laughing at your jokes
and this must mean comedy is dying Okay
so
it turns out Roseanne may have stole her
joke from one of the best that's ever
done a Ted Cruz got
took class to introduce herself
and to give her pronouns
well I'm Ted Cruz and my pronoun is kiss
my ass
that's crazy bro that that's crazy
because they they never heard this joke
wow and Benny thought it was so funny he
had to retweet it Eagle bro my brother
kiss my ass bro these are the reason why
Ted Cruz and Roseanne Barr have the same
joke and like half these [__] washed
up hacks have the same joke is because
they're not looking for laughter they're
not trying to get someone to go oh I
never thought about it that way that's
pretty funny they're trying to get this
okay and the moment that you're seeking
Applause rather than laughter to make
people laugh at something that is
objectively funny that they didn't think
before that's the moment you've lost
you're not a comedian anymore you're
just trying to do [__] Ted Talk okay
you're looking for validation from a
group of like-minded individuals and
that's not what's supposed to be funny
you know what's funny farts okay farting
on a dog very funny objectively funny
doesn't have to be brilliant doesn't
have to be [__] uh incredibly smart
or or have like this ideological message
behind it or George Carlin you know okay
so so that's your idea because somebody
is farting on dogs dude have you ever
seen a video of a guy farting on a dog
it is objectively hilarious yep
yeah see he's right okay I mean it's
better than whatever it's better I mean
it's bad definitely better I'm just
saying that like it doesn't have to
always be smart it doesn't have to
always be intelligent but it can be we
spent 30 minutes on Ethan eating
McDonald's uh yesterday people ate it Up
album well his comedy is Art that's what
I'm saying that's what I always said I
know we're out of time do you have five
more minutes because I want to talk
about this actually what Elon did which
is a real thing sure let's I'll blast
through it
because it sounds like you're you're
exaggerating when you say that but
you're 100 I'm not yeah that was a real
news story that happened this week
so elon's cousin sent an Urgent Message
to Twitter Engineers Monday morning
we are debugging an issue with the
engagement across the platform he tagged
everybody on slack any people who can
make it to the dashboard and write
software please can you help solve this
problem it's very high urgency if you
are willing to help out please thumb up
this post
here's the problem
Elon Musk tweet about the Super Bowl got
less engagement than Joe Biden's despite
having more followers he is washed
sleepy Joe Biden's tweet in which he was
uh supporting his wife and rooting for
the Eagles generated 29 million
impressions you guys
musk however tweeted his support for the
Eagles and it only got 9.1 million and
he was we were wondering why he erased
it because it's so [__] like beta and
weird well he also said go Eagles he
didn't even say go birds like you
[__] idiot he tagged them like the
team is going to be like hey Elon
mentioned go at Eagles like you're a
dumb ass dude oh my God
so why the American flag emojis is not
the eagle Emoji like it's right there
because he's a phony baloney big fan so
he deleted the Tweet because he was so
embarrassed with the low impression
count and Elon let's be honest some
tweets aren't great this tweet ads is
literally as nothing also does he not
understand that like does he not
understand that you know this is gonna
be
you're alienating half of the audience
automatically by taking a side on the
Super Bowl Biden supported the Eagles
and he got more Impressions Hassan is
clearly a bug in this system it's just
so after the game
Elon mad about his low Impressions I'm
mad about Joe Biden supporting the
Eagles did this actually happen yeah
yeah that's disgusting uh impeachable in
my opinion well it's his wife no one
should support Philadelphia
29 million impressions now that's a lot
this man I can respect he's juicing Elon
Musk million impressions cringe yeah so
Elon flies back
angry about his low Impressions back to
the Bay Area to demand answers from his
team within a day Twitter users opened
the app to find musk's posts were being
pushed to the top of their timeline a
lot of people noticed that
it's because Twitter deployed a code to
automatically green light all of musk's
tweets meaning his post will bypass
Twitter's filters designed to show
people the best content possible the
algorithm now artificially boosts must
tweets by a factor of one thousand in a
new yeah they use the new method like
that that they didn't have beforehand
um specifically like they tweaked the
algorithm specifically to show Elon Musk
tweets I didn't see a single one by the
way I I just really yeah I've never yeah
I don't actually I don't follow him the
thing is it doesn't have to me either
yeah anytime anyone you follow interacts
with them it shows it I don't know why I
didn't I was I was wondering that like I
didn't see a single [__] Elon Musk I
felt kind of out of no but like I also
kind of felt like I was not I follow him
just because I might be getting singled
out he might have he does he have you
blocked no but I have like I have
interacted with him a lot like I've I've
you know yelled at him a lot on Twitter
that makes it even here it's like a
hater list huh because I don't follow
him and the day after this like whenever
it was earlier this week I I noticed it
before the story even came out that like
half my feed was his [__] tweets so I
just I love that Elon Musk is just
consistently proving that uh we've been
right all along about Elon Musk and uh
and it's just like a petty thin-skinned
narcissistic egomaniacal billionaire
also so it took like to modify the
algorithm because he's butt hurt like
hello why are you guys looking up to
this insecure loser because they are
just as insecure and [__] dumb
because it all comes from it's not about
Free Speech it's about wanting
validation that's like 90 bro that is 90
of the motivating principle behind all
of these [__] divorced dads that are
like yeah [__] the lip tards you know
just just like my daughter uh whether
you're like a grandfather who has been
uh you know
pushed aside and your grandchildren no
longer want to talk to you because you
keep saying raise this [__] or whether
you're like a divorced dad who had to
leave your wife and children uh it's
just the same animosity and the same
resentment that they feel towards
liberalism it's not them they have ideas
they're Americans they are exceptional
human beings they're snowflakes those
ideas are unique they have to be heard
and not only do they have to be heard
they have to be consumed and appreciated
just by the sheer virtue of you thinking
it and saying it and they cannot
comprehend a world in which people are
just going to go no man you're a [__]
idiot like your jokes are not funny
you're kind of stupid you're kind of
racist and we don't [__] with that but
they can't comprehend that they're like
no there must be a systemic reason why
people think that my algorithms aren't
getting crushed cat turd is another
example of this he's just like
constantly talking about [__] poop
like he's Mozart cat turd is another
like uh you know leftovers conservative
Florida conservative meme account oh
that's like is that constantly talking
about [__] and like eating [__] and
sucking [__] and all this other stuff
and he's like yeah my algorithm is uh
you know really wonky Elon can you take
a look at this and elon's always like
concerning I'll take a look immediately
he does he loves all the The Fringe
conservative freaks on Twitter it's just
so these people ironically not to sound
too much like a [__] Boomer but these
people have not been told to shut the
[__] up they are they just like they
have never understood that like they are
not [__] okay
like Zoomers Millennials whatever like
the the generation that came after the
Baby Boomers and Gen X they have
constantly eaten [__] their whole lives
so they kind of like you know they're
they're angry they're resentful they're
they're upset at the system for
understandable reasons these guys that
come from uh infinitely more privileged
structural background
as a consequence of I don't know the GI
bill or all of these other like social
amenities that were offered to them
unconditionally at a time when America
had a 90 top marginal tax rate cannot
comprehend it like Society is actually
no longer designed for them that like
their jokes are not funny they're just
[__] old and washed but that is
really dark to to cope with so instead
of coping with that they're like well no
no reconfigure Society back to a point
where like everyone laughs at me and
loves my jokes about my [__] ex-wife or
my gender uh being kick your ass so
foreign
he's artificially boosted so that his
tweets rank higher than anyone else's
uh this was no accident so this was all
reported and confirmed by platformer who
first reported on this after talking to
employees at Twitter musk threatened to
fire his remaining Engineers if they
didn't build a system that ensured musk
has all of his tweets published to the
entire Twitter platform
musk has been obsessed with the amount
of Engagement his posts are receiving
last week Elon fired one of two
remaining principal engineers at the
company after the engineer told him that
views on his tweets are declining in
part because interest in musk has
declined in general
after the code was written for most
tweets to be pushed on the timeline Elon
tweeted out this tweet because people
were starting to notice and they're like
why the [__]
is elon's tweets all over
my timeline and so he does this and
people love it he's like yeah I I did it
he's like yeah I changed the algorithm
because I'm insecure
and this gets 1.4 million likes oh well
that's because it's pushed everyone's
feed this tweet had 10 katrillion uh
Impressions so congratulations hi
year long ma yeah so um
so that story is real
and it is very very embarrassing
real quick
um before we go since comedy is dead
this is Jim Brewer former cast of SNL
um uh he used to work with Dave
Chappelle he made the video halfway or
the movie Half Baked
this man is doing tours with the
conservative media and he is very funny
dude I love Yeah June Brewer I pulled
from the dock from we we watched this
like six months ago he was actually um
opening for uh don Jr in this clip okay
the the greatest comedic Duo of all time
yep he's warming up the crowd take a
look at what uh conservatives are
calling uh comedy like Don Jr is Don Jr
is really interesting to me because like
dude you have daddy issues and you do
Coke like you have like three two of the
three main markers of what would make a
good comedian like how did you fail so
much you know what I mean wow
a deep desire to also want to kill
yourself is like the final I guess
that's the that would that is what would
make the magic recipe for a good
comedian I'm not sure that's not there
I've seen his interactions with his dad
[Music]
let's try America
he wants to deep populate
you know the word be populated
it's a very nice word for murder
dude that's funny
when I got a lot of money and he really
pushed it he gets the good Charities
he's such a good guy
he gave us 14 million dollars he's such
a nice guy that is the power of money
money is driven party
yeah okay well we're done here but
there's one more I want to show you uh
just to give him his due credit as the
great comedian he is
right because he looks like a bird
who looks like a bird who's he talking
about he's stupid I don't know but he
does he's doing the cockatoo impression
like a lot
it's physical comedy dude come on you
understand that Ethan
this is good stuff that's what
everyone's become
the cockadoo little cockatoo staring at
the screen
faction figures faction figure
I was doing that a couple years ago he's
right I was
yeah
trust the science trust the science yeah
okay
and he's yeah comedy is yeah you would
think comedy's dead yeah like if this is
all you see watch your last numbers
going up
one Mass two my
if you're if you're a right-wing Guy
this is all you watch then yeah you'd be
like he's Rock comedy he's pretty [__]
up yeah I mean if you've that one was
actually pretty funny just in how
painfully and funny it was it it got me
laughing I will give him it was a
cockatoo
super into character and you know it's
pretty good if you've just been watching
um
Jimmy door maybe this guy is [__]
this is a step up and all-time great
all-time great yeah he's the goat yeah
for the goats so thank you Hassan nice
to see you again welcome back
nice to have you back it's only good
comedy it only gets better from here
folks
that's right
as we inch closer
to the meatballs first the diaper that's
what I call Trump the diaper I don't
know because he looks like he wears a
diaper how dare you diaper Don he just
has a feet
no he has a fat ass I like to tap that
for sure yeah because he is he's
probably so messy dude he has a juicy
ass yeah he's probably because he eats
like McDonald's he's definitely leaking
yeah you know you know that ass is
farting I'm sorry but I'm into that
actually all right let's hear that outro
music thanks everybody see you next week
see you tomorrow
to all my Super Troopers out there
see you guys tomorrow all right have a
great day God bless
[Music]